19h15 clos de couratier rentre du
travail ce quinquagénaire est magasinier
à dijon candidat aux municipales il est
tête de liste pour lutte ouvrière à
montceau-les-mines son programme
défendre les travailleurs
bon ça fait quand même des années qu'on
voit les l'état ou les mairies de
distribuer des subventions ou d'aidés
déroule le tapis rouge pour les grandes
entreprises mais au bout du compte de
toute façon ça ne ferait pas l'emploi
ils ont ils empochent le fait qu'ils
puissent en donc pour moi c'est une
élite massive et collective d'aidé lance
de la croissance de la classe ouvrière
qui post money à montceau comme ailleurs
quoi une vision marxiste assumé qui
détonne dans un scrutin municipal où les
enjeux locaux prime une stratégie qui
est un risque rebuter les électeurs et
donc faire moins de voix là aussi c'est
un choix je ne pense pas quand même
qu'on soit inhumé en tout cas déjà même
l'enjeu c'est quand même c'est d'être à
la lettre les yeux et les oreilles des
travailleurs lutte ouvrière présente 14
listes en bourgogne dans des villes au
long passé industriel
mais le parti a du mal à s'imposer aux
municipales en 2014
il est resté en dessous des 5% dans
plusieurs villes de saône et loire
depuis plusieurs décennies une partie de
l'électorat ouvrier s'est détournée des
partis de gauche
certains sont allés vers l'extrême
droite on a dit votez pour moi je crois
votre bonheur qui finalement au des sus
le monde ouvrier l'ont détourné du vote
où l'on fait se tourner vers l'extrême
droite par dépit ou c'est vraiment se
tirer une balle dans le pied c'est voter
pour des ennemis du moule ou voiliers
mouvement des gilet jaune contestation
de la réforme des retraites pour pascal
dufrègne tête de liste à chalon sur
saône
les vents sont désormais favorables un
retour de l'extrême gauche dans des
moments comme ça on verra les clivages
se refaire et j'espère et je suis
convaincu que les idées communistes
renaîtront à ce moment là et on tient
être au rendez vous réponse dans les
urnes dimanche prochain